Your hands help tell your life story—
—from the calluses of an expert bass player, to
the healed burns of a seasoned chef.
Hands can also help unveil the lives of those
from far before our time—our cousins the Neanderthals
who went extinct over 40,000 years ago.
Over the past decades, we’ve seen increasing
complexity in the remnants of the Neanderthal
lifestyle, such as small stone tools.
Although it was clear from their anatomy that
Neanderthal hands could form a precise, pincer-like
grip to make tools, interpretations of their
fossils have suggested they usually used a
different, more power-oriented grip.
New methods to analyze ancient bones have
reconciled our cultural understanding of Neanderthal
behavior with their fossilized remains.
The impressive leg muscles of an avid cyclist
or massive forearms on a drummer aren’t
preserved in fossils—but the attachments
of these hard working muscles leave scars behind—
marks that can tell us about the work they did.
Typically the greater the size of these marks,
called entheses, the stronger the muscle attached
to the bone.
A previous study of 19th century human bones
found a close relationship between life-occupation
and entheses.
Tailors or painters—those that performed
delicate, precise tasks—displayed a pattern
of entheses different from bricklayers or carpenters
that engaged in more intense manual labor.
These patterns reflect two categories of hand-grips:
“precision-grip” and “power grip.”
In precision grips, the thumb and index finger
do the heavy lifting, while power grips rely
more on the thumb and pinky.
Researchers used a 3D scanner to image early
modern humans and Neanderthal fossils, then
determined their hand-grip through rigorous
statistical analysis.
All the Neanderthals fossils were in the precision-grip
category, which supports archaeological evidence
of Neanderthals fashioning small stone tools.
A power grip would have been too strong
to create some of these delicately flaked tools.
In contrast, half the early modern human samples,
from around 40,000 years ago, displayed precision
gripping, while the other half displayed  power gripping.
In the future, these methods can be used to
provide insight about the hand-grip of other
early humans, as well as how these ancestors
used other muscles.
What answers do your hands hold?